I know that something that is high on
your agenda is becoming a mom yes I am
looking
big congrats are in order because the
reality star and her husband Carter ream
just announced they had a baby boy that
changes your whole life completely and
it's just
the true meaning of life and brings you
just so much joy and so much love that
you could never even have imagined
before so I'm I just can't wait for that
day one day on Tuesday Paris posted this
sweet snapped Instagram her little one's
tiny hand wrapped around her thumb
riding alongside it you are already
loved beyond words now a source tells ET
that they welcomed a baby boy via
surrogate saying Paris is so incredibly
happy and has always dreamed of being a
mom her friends and family are thrilled
for her and no she is going to be the
best mom I'm always going to be a boss
babe but I'm also going to be a grown-up
and I'll be a mom the surprise baby
announcement comes just a few months
after Paris revealed on Instagram that
she underwent IVF treatments and had
lots of healthy embryos ready and
waiting adding that nothing had her more
excited than the idea of becoming a mom
in 22 23 a sentiment she echoed to E.T
in November we have tons of eggs just
waiting to be brought into the world
so yeah we did that during the pandemics
was the perfect timing the world shut
down and just having that time where I
didn't have to travel and be everywhere
like a usual so I'm so happy that we did
that Paris and Carter tied the knot in
November 2021. how is newlywed life I'm
just loving it he's just so kind and
such an amazing husband and
we're just so excited to throw our life
together in the future What would what
would you say is the best part just
having your other half and your best
friend and just not I just don't even
like to go out anymore unless I have to
for work or something so it's nice just
to be able to just be at home and cook
and have a normal life and just enjoy
everything that I've worked so hard for
and now I finally get to enjoy it with
someone who I really love and trust and
it seems safe to say Paris finally got
her happily ever after I never let
anyone fully in until now and now I am
just so excited for that next step and
to get married and have babies and
just finally be as happy as I always
wished
[Music]